les emprunts toxiques des communes
endetté les journaux en parlent très
souvent mais avez-vous compris ce
qu'étaient ces fameux emprunts nous vous
avons posé la question les explications
ce sera juste
après des empreunt toxique alors là
aucune idée je peux pas vous dire pas
grand-chose sauf que c'est un petit peu
de la
spéculation sur des produits qui sont
fictifs je ne sais absolument rien
dessus non je sais pas du tout ce que
c'est faire des crédits réserves pas
forcément du bien rien non pas du tout
aucune idée un petit peu c'est sont les
emprunts qui permettent au maies de de
s'endetter mais qui
sont pris auprès de de certaines
sociétés comme Dexia et autres et qui
derrière ne permettent pas au mairie de
revenir dans leur fond enfin il y a un
truc comme ça
quoi allez pour tout comprendre de ces
empruns à présents claire campier
bonsoir bonsoir alors com comme on l'a
vu peu de personnes comprennent de quoi
il s'agit à part la dernière personne
qui qui était bien renseigné qui était
bien renseigné on espère qu'elle est pas
concernée par par l'ENF elle-même oui
parce que ça peut également concerern
des particuliers alors concrètement
qu'est-ce que c'est un emprunt toxique
c'est un emprunt structuré qui a disons
mal tourné donc un emprunt structuré
c'est un emprunt taux variable
c'est-à-dire que le taux d'intérêt varie
en fonction de l'indice financier sur
lequel il est indexé à l'inverse un taux
fixe donc ne bouge pas on lui dit
structurer parce qu'il comprend
plusieurs périodes donc une première
période dit à taux bonifier où le taux
d'intérêt est très bas puis une deuxième
période dont le taux d'intérêt est
indexé à une formule elles peuvent être
différentes par exemple le taux
d'intérêt peut-être indexé comme on le
verra tout à l'heure sur la parité euro
franc suisse c'est-à-dire que sur si le
rapport pardon euro franc suisse bouge
le taux bouge également alors un exemple
concernant une commune par exemple alors
on va prendre une commune lambda qui
aurait contract un un emprunt donc
structuré auprès d'une banque disons que
l'encours que l'emprunt pardon court sur
30 ans pendant 3 ans le taux d'intérêt
va être très faible disons à 1 % puis
pendant 27 ans le taux sera indexé à une
formule avec un taux de base à 3 %
disons que la différence entre euro et
francs suisse est de 1,45 c'est-à-dire
qu' 1 € est égal à 1,45 Francs Suisse le
taux proposé est à l'ORS de 3 %
seulement si le rapport entre euro et
franc- Suisse reste fixe ou est
supérieur à 1,45 donc si l'euro perd de
sa valeur le taux de 3 % augmente de 50
% de la dépréciation extrêmé en
pourcentage on va expliquer un peu mieux
c'est-à-dire que si le franc suisse
s'apprécie ou ce qui a été le cas
dernièrement puisque le franc suisse est
une valeur refuge et qu' 1 € ne vaut
plus 1 € 1 franc suisse 45 mais 1,35 le
rapport entre l'euro et le franc suisse
a perdu 10 % par rapport à la barrière
du coup on a donc 3 % le taux d'intérêt
initial plus 5 % qui correspond à 10 %
des 50 % on arrive du coup à 8 % au lieu
des 3 % c'est plus du double
véritablement sont des gros gros somme
ça devient tout de suite très important
voilà le tout explose et c'est comme ça
que l'emprunt devient toxique puisque
tous les emprunts à taux variable ne
sont pas forcément toxiques donc la Cour
des comptes a dénoncé dans son rapport
annuel de 2009 l'opacité et les dangers
des empreuns structurés pour les
collectivités une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur les emprunts toxiques
au collectivité a d'ailleurs chiffré
l'an dernier le volume de ces prês à 18
,8 milliards d'euros et il y a des
communes dans le département des
ivelines qui sont concerné et oui
évidemment il y a plusieurs communes de
concernées comme Montini bois d'Arc les
clés sousbois ou encore plaisir et
rouillé dont on parlera dans cette
chronique ça a été au cœur de
l'actualité il y a quelques mois
quelques années même au moment des des
crises des subprime et autres on a
beaucoup parlé de ces encins toxiques
pourquoi on en reparle aujourd'hui al on
en reparle aujourd'hui puisque le
département de Sens a obtenu
l'animulation de trois prêts contracté
auprès de la banque d'xia c'est taux ont
été remplacés par des taux d'intérêt
légal par le taux d'intérêt légal pardon
la banque a bien sûr fait appel de cette
décision mais si finalement le TGI de
Nanterre qui a rendu cette décision
cette décision pardon est validée je
vais y arriver ça pourrait donc faire
jurisprudence et évidemment plusieurs
communes pourraient imiter ce
département pour l'instant aucune
commune s'est engouffré dans la brèche
dans le département alors certaines
villes donc il y a Rony sur sur scène
pardon qui un peu plus loin en septembre
2011 p déposer plainte au pénal et puis
suite à la décision du TG inentaire
rouillé et plaisir ont déposé plainte au
civil ou vont le faire contre Dex la
Caisse d'Épargne on va parler de
l'exemple de plaisir d'ailleurs voilà
puisque nous avons sur ce plateau
Bernard hsard bonjour bonsoir élu
d'opposition du coup à Plaisir
exactement alors cette assignation en
justice qui a été décidée par la mairie
tout récemment la semaine dernière c'est
une bonne chose ben écoutez oui c'est
une bonne chose alors déjà pour
commencer je je regrette d'être un peu
seul sur ce plateau j'a alors du coup je
suis obligé de vous interrompre dès le
début c'est juste pour préciser les
choses effectivement puisque nous avions
convié he la mère sur ce plateau elle
n'a pas souhaité venir pour être tout à
fait clair c'est tout simplement parce
que les élections municipales sont dans
un an vous êtes un candidat déclaré
d'opposition sur sa commune la mère n'a
pas encore fait état clairement de sa
position et pour elle la campagne de
toute façon n'a pas encore commencé ce
qui explique que pour l'instant elle ne
souhaitait pas de confrontation et de
face à face c'était pas lié au thème
c'était plus lié au calendrier avec ses
échéances ite voà du coup l'interview a
été faite on va l'écouter et on
l'écoutera dans un instant puisque nous
l'avons rencontré voilà donc oui donc ce
que je ce que je voulais dire
effectivement pour répondre à votre
enfin à votre question bien entendu que
on est satisfait de cette décision que
l'on réclamait depuis 2009 déjà hein
donc on avait fait on avait identifié le
le risque potentiel qu'avait notre
commune en ayant souscrit ce type de
contrat on avait fait un travail de fond
et depuis cette année 2009 on ne cessait
au travers des réunions de budget ou de
débat d'orientation budgétaire de
réclamer qu'il y ait une action qui soit
engagée et qu'il y ait plus de
transparence sur ce dossier chose que
l'on a eu du mal à faire entendre et
effectivement euh très récemment puisque
ça date du conseil municipal d'avril
suite je pense à l'action qu'a engagé
monsieur Larcher à Rambouillet plaisir
curieusement à emboîter le pas et donc
on est maintenant dans cette démarche
alors est-ce que ça signifie
qu'aujourd'hui plaisir dans une une
situation compliquée par rapport à bah
oui on est dans une situation compliquée
malgré tout ce que voudrait nous faire
penser la majorité actuelle on est
rentré dans les phases que l'on appelle
les phases à taux variable je pense
qu'on en discutera peut-être un petit
peu plus après avec des des graphiques
et déjà dès l'année 2012 dès le mois de
mars 2012 la ville de plaisir a été
obligé de procéder à une nouvelle
renégociation d'un des emprs d'un des
emprunts pardon les plus top toxique qui
est indexé sur le Fran Suisse et donc
par cette renégociation a dû bloquer
pendant 2 ans le taux à un taux qui est
de 848 au lieu de 3,45 initialement mais
dès dès l'année 2014 nous repasserons
dans ces périodes à taux variables qu'il
faut rappeler qu'il sont des taux
variables sans plafond hein donc on peut
monter à des à des extrêmes très très
important alors nous avons posé cette
même question est-ce que finalement les
les comptes de la ville sont sont en
difficulté posé cette question à la mère
de plaisir je vous propose d'écouter sa
réponse d'accord la ville va bien malgré
ses emprints structurées parce que notre
ville vous le savez a eu un endettement
très important quand on est arrivé en
2001 il s'avère queaujourd'hui on est
dans un endettement en baisse puisque de
78 millions nous sommes passés à 54 et
quelques 55 on va dire pour arrondir il
est vrai que c'est un effort énorme me
tout en sachant que parallèlement à cela
et bien on a investi plus de 100
millions d'euros pendant tout pendant
ces 12 années ce qui veut dire que on a
une gestion très très saine il faut
savoir que c'est surtout sur la dette
aujourd'hui de la ville qui est de 55
millions d'euros c'est une dette sur
laquelle nous avons 14 millions
d'emprunts structurés les plus
difficiles c'est c'est cela qui nous
pose souci c'est ces 14 ce sont ces 14
millions là qui effectivement était
parti sur un envol de plus de 12 % et on
voyait même les 25 % V IR mais
aujourd'hui ils sont figés à 838 au
moins pour 2 années donc on espère que
sur ces deux années on va pouvoir aller
encore audà donc vous voyez les 14
millions sur les 55 je dis pas que c'est
une broutille hein c'est quelque chose
de fondamental et d'important on est
très vigilant là-dessus mais sachez que
nous on peut on peut faire nos
remboursements sans problématique et en
même temps chaque année on a une épargne
positive très importante cette année
elle est de 5 mil009 presque 6 millions
d'épagnees positives ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui tous les inv invessement
que nous faisons sur la ville et diocè
s'il y en a puisqu'on a deux énormes
projets en plus de l'Église qui est
derrière moi et qui est un projet
colossal et bien nous pouvons les
financer sans emprunt
supplémentaire alors ce qu' ce qu'elle
nous explique donc c'est c'est 14
millions finalement ça ça n'est qu'un
emprunt ça n'est pas la totalité des
emprunts toxiques qu'a contracté la
ville est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer un petit peu la part des
emprunts toxiques dans la part de la
dette oui donc comme l'a expliqué madame
le Maire donc à l'intérieur de la dette
aujourd'hui on a 70 % de d'emprunt
toxique 70 % qui sont répartis sur
quatre emprunts donc effectivement avec
des niveaux de toxicité euh différentes
puisque le plus important de 14 millions
est sur le franc suisse mais derrière
cela on a également un emprunt qui est
indexé sur le le dollar par rapport au
yen un autre qui est indexé sur l'euro
l'euro doollar par rapport à l'euro
franc suisse hein et un 3ème sur une une
devise qui s'appelle le Libor US 12 USD
12 mois bon et donc dans ces dans ces
quatre dans ces quatre emprunt donc on a
celui qui est le plus toxique mais on en
a un autre aussi qui est à échéance du
mois de mai qui est aujourd'hui dans un
niveau au-dessus de du taux contracté à
l'origine hein donc on est dans un
multiplicateur de 18 hein c'està-dire
que les intérêts seront 1,8 fois
supérieur à ce qui était prévu au
contrat et dans le dans les deux autres
il y en a un qui commence à approcher la
barrière hein c'est celui qui s'appelle
le le Libor USD hein qui est en train de
de s'approcher dangereusement de la de
la barrière donc on pourrait dire qu'on
en a un rouge un rose un orange et puis
un qui est au vert mais on voit bien que
quand madame le Maire explique que la
gestion est saine à Plaisir la question
n'est pas de savoir si la gestion est
saine la question est aujourd'hui on est
en train de payer une masse d'intérêts
qui n'était pas prévu dans les contrats
qui n'avait pas pas été bien identifié
qui pour l'année 2012 ont représenté 1
million et demi d'intérêts
supplémentaires ça va être la même chose
sur 2013 1 million et demi pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée c'est le budget
du CCAS ou l'agrandissement d'une école
qui a eu lieu dans un de nos quartiers
Centre d'Action communale voilà le
Centre d'Action communale pour être bien
clair vous nous avez préparé un petit
graphique justement sur ex sur la parité
franc Fran Suiss euro donc c'est c'est
de démographiqu si on peut le le voir
peut-être voilà donc là on voit l'indice
donc c'est un peu l'exemple que j'avais
donné avec envers euh ce qui est la
barrière ou au-dessus de la barrière
donc la parité 1,45 et puis avec le le
franc suisse qui s'apprécie l'indice
descend et et a chuté voilà et on voit
que en mai enfin ou en août 2011
lapparité Suisse était quasiment euros
Suisse était quasiment à l'équilibre un
pour un et donc on a arrivait sur ce
fameux emprunt à un taux qui arrivait à
22 % alors que le nominal était à 3,45
et donc on voit bien à quoi la ville est
exposée pour des durées très importantes
parce que le problème c'est que dans ces
renégociations qui ont eu lieu en 2008
on est passé d'un plan d'amortissement
qui était sur 20 ans globalement à 30
ans c'est-àdire qu'on a allongé la durée
d'amortissement et donc il y a une une
durée importante dans une dans un taux
qui est variable et est non plafonné
c'est ça le le problème c'est qu'il est
non plafonné donc on est d'une certaine
façon on est quasiment incapable de
savoir à 3 ans ce que l'on aura à payer
si on si on maintient ces eau en l'état
où ils sont aujourd'hui sans parler des
des condition de renégociation qui sont
des justement vous parlez de
renégociation une autre ville donc du
coup des éilines rambouillé est
également touché par ses empreunts le
maire Gérard arché a d'ailleurs indiqué
qu'il a qu'il a signé en justice Dex et
la Caisse d'épargne leur gestion des
emprunts a été différente puisqu'ils ont
renégocié pour avoir un taux fixe à de
88 donc le maire n'a pas souhaité
communiquer sur ses emprunts mais nous
allons écouter Jean-Luc trantignon élu
d'opposition PS sur ce
sujet vous vous laissez passer les les
deux trois années où c'est sécurisé à un
tau bas et vous rachetez votre emprunt
vous le renégociez pour un autre au lieu
de de devenir victime de des taux
d'intérêts extrêmement forts c'est ce
qui est fait à Rambouillet mais alors on
a des pénalités extrême en conséquence
je vous dis ce sera 100 millions d'euros
nets euh là il y a déjà 8 millions
d'euros nets engagés malgré les périodes
où de bonification du du début euh c'est
absolument
scandaleux alors il annonce 10 millions
de de pénalités net donc 4 millions 4
millions c'est le chiffre pour 2012 qui
a été acté et noté par par la mairie euh
de leur côté donc au 1er janvier la
dette globale était de plus de 42
millions d'euros alors est-ce est-ce que
la ville de plaisir il est envisageable
de payer ces pénalités pour descendre le
le taux à une un chiffre raisonnable
disons écoutez euh j'ai un peu de mal à
vous répondre
égard le le montant colossal aujourd'hui
qui est inscrit dans les contrats hein
puisque le contrat qui a été renégocié
en en en 2012 fait apparaître un chiffre
de 33 millions d'euros hein pour en
terme
d'indemnité pour pour renégocier ce prêt
alors
euh ce ce niveau de 33 millions est
quelque chose qui qui évolue parce que
c'est c'est intimement lié au cours au
cours de la devise en question par
rapport à l'euro mais je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait se
mettre dans cette situation de pouvoir
payer ou de devoir payer ce ce ce
montant colossal donc ça ne passe que
par des renégociations et la démarche
qui est engagée aujourd'hui hein qui
était ce que l'on souhaitait hein pour
voir comment qu'est-ce qui peut être
fait pour revenir à la fois
vers des des des des emprunts je dirait
de formules standard hein et comment
avec les banques il y a moyen de
trouver entre guillemets un compromis si
je dois dire ainsi pour nous verrons
donc ce que donne la décision de du TG
indentire et
puis la décision suite à l'appel de la
banque merci pour ces précisions la
chronique de à présent c'est l'info en
plus alors une info en plus oui les prix
baissent dans l'immobilier donc dans les
Yvelines les prix des transactions
immobilières sur le marché l' l'ancien
ont reculé de 1,6 % contre 0,8 en
Île-de-France en 2012 et tout logement
confondu les prix ont chuté de 1,9 % par
rapport à 2011 cela s'explique par une
baisse des ventes puisque le leur nombre
a diminué en un an de 24 %. l'agenda à
présent avec de dates à retenir alors de
dates à retenir premièrement un atelier
pour mieux communiquer alors mieux
communiquer pour ses entretiens de
recrutement d'évaluation en utilisant
les techniques du théâtre c'est un peu
original c'est organisé par la compagnie
Déclic Théâtre et ce sera le 7 mai et
puis une deuxième date à retenir un
petit duner d'information pourquoi
aborder la question de
l'intergénérationnelle dans votre
entreprise ça se passe dans le cadre des
Rencontres de la diversité ce sera lieu
le vendredi 17 mai c'est organisé par le
club face merci Claire la chronique de
l'cho c'est tous les jeudis sur TVFI
dans le 78